In this lesson we're going to go over the outline for the introduction for lighting
for this series of courses
and then we're also going to be looking at terminology and types.
So let's get started.
So the course outline for these series of videos
is first we're going to look at lighting terminology and types.
That entails lighting definitions and types, static versus dynamic, and light types overall.
Later on we'll look at lighting properties and settings,
light properties and how to control them, and light mobility and how it plays with your light
concerning which type of light, GI, global illumination, direction you're going.
Then we'll look at an introduction to Lumen.
What is Lumen?
How to set it up, quality control, tips and tricks, and Lumen visualize.
Later we'll look at Nanite and virtual shadow maps,
why use Nanite, using it, how to set it up,
and virtual shadow maps as an overall whole view of how it works.
Later on we'll look at lighting tools, environment light mixer,
and light mixer, and we're going to do an interactive build
of light for our hero object that I've given to you guys
and it'll be a lot of fun.
So let's go ahead and take a look at lighting terminology and types
and how that's all working with Unreal.
First up we'll look at direct lighting.
What does that mean?
When it comes to this real time scenario,
a lot of people can be unfamiliar with Unreal,
specifically in lighting because real time is very different
than an offline render.
In this particular case, direct lighting is a light
that falls onto the surface without any interference.
The light travels directly to the surface
and that surface receives the full color spectrum of light.
We also have indirect lighting.
You'll see that many times in the details
for particular lights that you're working with.
It's a lighting that has been reflected by other surfaces nearby
as the light bounces off these surfaces,
light waves are absorbed or reflected
based on the surface's properties
and passed onto the surface you were looking at.
Thus indirect lighting contributes to the mood
and overall light intensity.
We also have shadows.
Now there's several ways to approach shadows,
but in Unreal there's the bake method
and you'll see in Unreal takes a snapshot of the mesh actor
from light's point of view and projects that information
on another mesh actor on the opposite side.
In the case of virtual shadow maps,
shadows update in real time using mesh distance fields
for accurate calculations and updates with movable lights.
So static versus dynamic.
What does that exactly mean when it comes Unreal?
Let's break this down.
We have a brand new system that came through with Unreal 5
and that is Lumen.
It's our fully dynamic global illumination
and reflection system
that is designed for next generation consoles,
but it is not limited to consoles or games.
It can be used for Final Pixel.
It can be used for VR training or VR experiences
and it can be used for virtual production.
It is the default global illumination
and reflection system in Unreal currently.
Lumen renders diffuse,
inter-reflection with infinite bounces
and indirect specular reflections and large detailed environments
at scales ranging from millimeters to kilometers.
So it's really nicely optimized
so it can scale down nicely to your needs.
Now, baked static lighting and also stationary,
which stationary is used in that particular direction,
is pre-computed rendered lighting.
Baked lighting is created using Unreal's
Lightmass Radiosity Baker.
And you'll see that when the thing called swarm,
you'll see it on the bottom of your screen
or swarm agent,
which will appear if you are using the baking system.
It'll be on the bottom right hand side typically.
It is similar to rendering lighting with V-Ray
or Corona, et cetera.
It is used to create high quality indirect lighting
using light and shadow maps.
Baked lighting cannot be altered at runtime
but has little impact on real-time performance.
Now, static lighting is your primary baked source.
Stationary light is used within that scenario.
Stationary light can be used for movable objects,
for objects moving in the environment
and static would not affect those lights.
So there's a lot of give and take.
You have to be very strategic
and deterministic when using baked lighting.
But baked lighting can give you some really cool results
at a cheap cost,
yet not quite as realistic or performance ready
as Lumen when it comes to being able to change things on the fly.
Now, real-time that takes us to our next topic,
real-time dynamic lighting.
It's lighting that is updated each frame.
It is fully dynamic and can be moved around
and modified at runtime.
It has no global illumination component, only direct light.
It is also expensive to use, affects a real-time performance.
Now, dynamic light in the sense that you're outside of Lumen,
say you used a dynamic light in baked mode,
you're not going to get the GI
that you're necessarily going for.
But that's where Lumen kind of breaks the mold.
Unreal can use both static and dynamic lighting.
That's that note here.
So architectural visualization will do this sometimes,
although now they're using more of Lumen.
But the projects, the project assets,
typically stationary in baked static lighting
is mostly used older way.
Now, Lumen can be used,
but there is currently some reflection limitations.
So when you're using Lumen,
you're going to be leaning more towards fully dynamic.
Real light is movable
and Lumen will give you global illumination.
So that's kind of breaking the old mold.
It's basically the new guard.
It's a new way to do things.
Now, before Lumen, there was ray tracing.
So ray tracing, this type of lighting
is real-time global illumination
updated with all lights set to movable.
If they are animated, the GI updates on the fly
and the same thing goes with Lumen
because Lumen borrows some of that architecture.
Note some aspects of ray tracing
is taken into account with Lumen
as you see in the bottom here,
such as reflections and some light calculations.
So each one of these has a very specific mindset
when you start diving into it.
Now, we're not going to get into ray trace
for this first course,
but we will talk about Lumen specifically.
We're not going to get into baking
and how to work with a baking scenario.
That is for the other classes,
more advanced classes coming down the pipe.
But for the most part,
we're going to be focusing more on Lumen.
So the types of lights and how to use them.
We're going to get more into the properties
and how to edit them.
But for this particular section,
we're going to just give you an overview
on how these work.
So directional light.
Awesome.
It works just like a regular directional light
you would have with Maya or 3D Studio Max
or many other 3D packages.
It is your primary sunlight.
There's also the point light.
Notice I put Omni here.
Well, if you're more of a 3D Studio Max person,
you'll get that point.
It works kind of like a bulb or a mini sunlight
and it can be used definitely
for particular scenarios.
There's the spotlight,
which is your typical spotlight with Unreal.
Has that per number and has a cone angle.
All those things can be controlled.
We also have the rec light.
The rec light is great.
Now you hear me repeat this several times.
The rec light is like a series of point lights
within a square that can be shaped into a rectangle
and many shapes and forms.
We'll get into that later.
It is one of my favorite ones for fill light.
It works fantastic.
Then we also have the skylight.
Now the skylight is used many times
with architectural rendering.
They'll pull into the scene
and I like to use it too
because it gives me a nice little GI bounce everywhere.
Your skylight can also be attached to an HDR image
if you want to.
Otherwise it will use the information,
the data and the scene to bounce your light around
but you can load an HDR image
such as ones you can get at HDR Haven.
They're working really great
and those are open source.
There's also HDR backdrop
which is similar to the skylight
but in the fact that it is a backdrop
where you can actually see the image
but it will also bounce the light around
like you would with a skylight.
So it's using the HDRI backdrop.
It's a predefined HDR.
Now this one typically is used a lot of times for product
and for vehicles.
It's not necessarily used for in a game scenario
and if it's used for virtual production
and you just need something down and dirty
it might be perfect in some scenarios
and but not really for final pixel or for video games
and the fact that if you turn your camera
you can kind of see that it's kind of fake
but it works really great
has a lighting blueprint set up for it
and it may be great for what you want to do, may not
but if you want realism
you might want to steer more towards directional light
skylight and a few of the other lights
depending on your scene
but it's really great.
A lot of our product people use them
our clients such as automotive
and architectural
and the next we have sun in sky
so this lighting blueprint
allows you to pull this into the scene
and makes it so that you can change the time of day
using longitude and latitude
and we're not going to get really deep into these last two
these were covered in some other classes
but for the most part we're going to be covering
skylight, rec light, spotlight, point light, and directional light.
The sun in sky is great
because you can actually drag it into a scene
and then you can punch
again like I said
you can punch in your exact time of day that you need
longitude, latitude, time of day, and so forth.
Now it's not quite as robust as you would get
as I think 3D Studio Max is one
and I think Maya also has one
with the longitude and latitude
Max is a little bit more robust I believe
but it gets pretty close.
That's it with this course
and you can see we have a link here
if you want to dive in a little deeper
in the next course we're going to look at
lighting properties and settings.
Thanks again.